so yeah things are gonna be changing a
little bit so I doing this a little bit
sooner than I had expected to you know
since the last time I did it but yeah a
little bit of a state of the channel and
sort of a shifting of how things are
gonna start to be a little bit different
I'm not drastically overhauling the
channel I am not stopping doing this if
those are the things you're worried
about don't that's none of that's gonna
happen sort of the staple stuff that I
do isn't going anywhere and isn't
changing but some of the more ancillary
stuff on the channel is going to either
change or kind of go away a little bit
and I'll explain before I do allow me to
be a little bit of a completely
shameless shilla for myself and mention
hey it's March you know what happens in
March my birthday so if anyone's feeling
particularly generous and you feel like
sending me stuff p.o box address is in
the description just saying okay that's
enough of that so um well I I want to
start with kind of why I'm looking to
shift the way I do things I'm not burned
out I'm not burned out exhausted like Oh
to do it anymore not even with the daily
schedule I actually could could keep it
going but I am going to back off and
videos are not going to be every single
day anymore and there's a couple of
reasons for that largely the primary
reason honestly it has to do with the
growth of the channel which is to say
that actually pretty much since we've
gotten into the new year it hasn't grown
much it's actually stagnated in the
month of February
especially quite a bit and and I've I
feel like I've gotten a handle on what
it is that's going on because I I had I
had some days where I had little panic
Bauman's I had a day where I lost 20
subscribers like net that was my net for
that day was a 20 subscriber loss and
that's the kind of thing that can send
yo creator into a bit of a panic but
when I looked into it a little bit more
detailed it gave me a clearer picture
which is that I'm not actually losing
more subscribers than I do
normally I mean subscriber turnover is a
typical thing and actually these first
two months of this year I'm averaging
lower numbers in terms of subscriber
loss than I did you know on an average
month last year the difference is I no
longer am getting the new subscribers in
to counteract the standard turnover and
that's where things are off right now
I'm not new people aren't finding me and
I don't know how much of that is YouTube
and their algorithm just messing with me
or or what but what I can tell you is
that part of the reason that I kept the
motivation going to do the daily videos
for as long as I did was that it did
appear to actually be helping me in
terms of visibility of the channel and
growth for it and like before I continue
I don't want to sound like I'm overly
click obsessed but the thing is right
now the channel is at a really
frustrating point where with a bit more
of a push it's not out of the realm of
possibility that I could get it to where
this would be what I do for a living but
I'm not there yet and it's difficult to
put in the time in the effort to get
there while still maintaining a
full-time day job so like I am at a
point where I think other well actually
I know there are other channels my sizes
are even slightly smaller that have made
the leap to doing this full-time but
generally from
people who have less expenses than I do
you know I got a house I got a kid yeah
it's it's I I think I have a few more
life expenses you know to cover I I have
a in terms of what I need to make to
actually pay all my bills but um you
know I I don't want it to seem like I'm
just like I'm reeling for the clicks
like well no but if what I'm doing is
sort of has hit a ceiling that means if
I ever want to get to the point that I'd
like to be at which is just doing this
as my job then I can't keep doing what
I'm doing because it's not growing
anymore
so here's what does not change Doctor
Who videos two times a week does not
change you will still get a sunday video
rotating topic and that's where classic
episode reviews and Big Finish reviews
and lists and editorial ramblings all
that will still happen on Sundays
overdue Doctor Who review that's not
going anywhere that remains on
Wednesdays those stay the same the
lgbtq+ topics once a month those stay
where they are and the approach will
stay the same what you will see less of
is you will see less sort of hot takes I
I'm gonna become more selective about
which breaking news items or new
trailers I actually devote full videos
to because that's one of the ways I
would kind of fill out the schedule is
to take something go can I get 10
minutes out of that I think so let's try
it like the sort of how I'm sort of
prioritizing this uh yeah I wouldn't now
you know do a video on hey Marvel's
gonna make a shang-chi master of kung-fu
movie I probably wouldn't devote a video
to that now with the sort of the way I'm
reprioritizing it doesn't mean I won't
talk about smaller stuff like that but
that sort of conversation is going to
get moved
/ - the weekly livestream which happens
on Tuesdays alternating 7:00 p.m. or
9:00 p.m. Eastern Time the next one I
don't know which it's going to be but
Tuesday's every week I've actually been
able to maintain that schedule and if I
ever need to take a week off I'll give
folks a heads-up but that's where I'm
gonna move the a lot of the sort of hot
taste stuff that I feel like I don't I
don't feel the motivation to devote a
full video to this I'll probably still
do full videos for like first trailers
for something but you know when it's
like second or third trailer unless it's
really spark something my head probably
won't be de vide devoting videos to that
any more other stuff the stuff that has
been sporadic will remain sporadic you
know things like good movie bad ending
the animation junkie reviews I'll
probably do some more 90s comics retrial
they pick rants you know all the things
like that you know I do want to I do
want to get Liz back and do some more of
the of the sorting various fictional
universe characters and the Hogwarts
houses so you know that stuff will still
happen but none of that was ever on a
fixed schedule the only stuff that was
on a regular schedule was the LGBTQ
stuff and the Doctor Who stuff at all
that staying and the other stuff will
get slotted in as I can along with the
course patreon sponsored reviews as they
come up so what does that mean in terms
of what I do with what I put out
you know because otherwise I'm just like
doing less content well I want to take
the extra time that I'm gonna end up
with as a result of not doing daily
videos and I want to try and produce
stuff that's a little bit more work
intensive I'm actually going to take a
crack at basically the video essay
format now I don't plan to like
drastically shake-up the format of the
stuff that I'm already doing or you know
doing
again the LGBTQ stuff and the and the
Doctor Who stuff that'll that I don't
think is going to change really at all
but you know for for maybe one of the
patreon sponsored reviews I might roll
the dice and try and integrate more
editing stuff actually maybe try video
clips which is something I've avoided in
the past because dealing with the
copyright claims is a big headache but
the thing is and I've realized this more
firmly as sort of views have eased off
for me I can't really count on the
YouTube revenue if this is ever gonna be
my living I need to be making most if
not all of my living expenses strictly
off the patreon because you know while
support on the patreon can go up it can
go down it can it will it gives me a
bait a base level and I can monitor that
a heck of a lot better and understand
what's going on with it
better than YouTube because you know
whether or not a video spreads or
doesn't is really hard for me to be able
to judge stuff that used to get higher
views maybe isn't stuff that I don't
expect give news might get a heck of a
lot more than I expect and I don't like
trying to plan paying bills around that
so I don't know what to do as far as
trying to bolster the patreon more the
last time I kind of did a bit of a call
to action on it I there was an amazing
swell of support and it has continued to
grow since then but I also don't want to
come across like I'm begging or like I'm
holding the channel to ransom I don't
like that feeling I don't like that idea
but at the same time that you know
subscriber growth is great more views is
wonderful I do want that and if I could
get a higher sort of minimum sustain
level of income from YouTube that would
certainly help but like it but if this
is ever gonna be my little bit hat
I need it to come through the patreon I
needed to come through a through a
source that I can I can just rely on a
little bit more than YouTube and to not
yoyo month-to-month but at the same time
I don't really want to push it any
harder than I already have been oh one
other thing
I suppose don't mention this I actually
will have a sponsor for some episodes
this will be a first for me I've had
potential sponsors reach out to me
before but for one reason another I I
haven't bitten at any of those this one
is a guy actually guided that I know and
is a really cool stuff and I mean you'll
know when it happens so I suppose that's
worth pointing out I'm certainly open to
sponsorships I am gonna be nitpicky and
vet them like I said I've been
approached before and I've turned that
stuff down but I I'm just I'm just
trying to find the ways to to to shore
this up but yes so ideally with fewer
videos happening per week with some of
them I do want to start devoting more
time into them to try and produce a
slightly more polished finished product
you will still get me rambling on you
know without a script for stuff for
reviews primarily I mean if I'm gonna
review something where it where I'm not
you know trying to make a grandeur point
I'll probably still just ramble like a
camera so if that's what you like it's
not going away but I want to try and
grow and I want to try to expand because
if I just keep doing what I've already
been doing then the channels not gonna
get any bigger and while that hasn't
caused me to lose motivation yet I do
worry that growth flatlining will cause
me to burnout and I don't want that to
happen so I'm gonna wrap it up there so
some changes coming hopefully for the
better hopefully you'll stick with me
hopefully the council gets bigger and
more expensive and more vibrant and
maybe I get a little better at what I do
who knows we'll see thanks for your
support
you know I if you haven't supported me
up the patreon I encourage you to do
that there are rewards even at the
lowest offering but even if you don't if
all you're doing is watching
that's support and I appreciate that too
so changes yeah they're happening also
my birthday because I'm getting older
remind you of that peel boxes down there
so is the patreon link so is also the
comments that you can leave so whatever
your thoughts are drop something down
there and let's talk about a whole bunch
of stuff to do it's all down in the
description but even if you don't click
on any of it that's ok too because at
the end of the day you are the council I
am just running these dang meetings
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]